Kendall is she dating Harry Styles  that's a good question there were a lot  of pictures out they were what are you  seeing out together at home do you guys  think they're dating yes yes but do I  know what like I don't know if they're  like boyfriend/girlfriend I don't know  people are weird with stuff so I don't  know their title but I mean they were in  st. Barts together hanging feels like  David yeah but I don't know like I don't  know what they're you know you have the  talk I don't know if they've had that  talk the talk yeah don't do people still  have the talk  I've been married so long I don't know  about the talk anymore the talk I don't  believe in just assuming what you are I  agree that's ridiculous  you had to talk with James you have to I  don't believe you cannot not have the  top like we need to understand fully  what is our relationship rubba like no  I'm not gonna lose still until I'm too  grown for that oh I like that  that's two or  you